[Music]
you've been extremely successful how
many races have you won almost a
thousand and coming close that's
incredible
give me the idea a very successful
jockey wins about what percentage of
their races because there's so much
that's not in your control yeah we lose
80% of the time okay yeah so it's like
comedy as well trust me I can relate how
long were you a professional before your
first win I wrote 20 races and I won my
first race Wow yeah that's amazing and
there's a tradition there's an old
tradition with that they do with jockeys
when they win their first professional
race what is that tradition it's kind of
like hazing maybe not so mean and when
you win your first race to come the
jocks room and they basically crack eggs
in your head pour water on you and shoe
polish you know places where you don't
really want but I got lucky because I
was one of the girls so they were like
she touch they put shoe polish in places
you don't really want it would be any
place other than my shoe that's the
definition for me
what an odd what are these what are
these traditions come from but it's
these it's like sticks on your skin for
a week like I don't know yeah no it's
very unpleasant you wonder who thought
of this I've got an idea whenever a
jockey wins with crack eggs on their
heads and rubbed shoe polish where the
Sun don't shine
stupid thing to think of now a great
honor that you've had is you worthy I
think the first athlete who's had an
advertisement on their backside we have
the ad right here and tell us what is
going on congratulations on this high
honor what is it what's happening here
that's a barcode of some kind yeah it's
a barcode it was someone's idea to you
can scan the barcode and you're right
into TV G and you can start making your
bets for racing it's for off-track
betting yeah okay it's an ad for
off-track betting on your butt okay all
right our director keeps putting the
photo up he won't take it down
he's obsessed so someone pitched you
that idea and you said let's go for it
well you know my manager Angie she's
fantastic and we got a lot of money for
that so yeah you know I love I admire
the honesty and I'm not arguing with you
they paid me a lot of money I want in on
that no one wants to see that on me no
thank you one of you does oh wait that
was sarcastic you were recently this is
an amazing photograph I'll compliment
you on this photo ahead of time you
recently photographed by Bo Derek for
Vanity Fair magazine let's take a look
at this photo right here incredible
photograph how did are you completely
naked for this Wow okay I have stickies
stickies yeah not just use shoe polish
to come
and I had actually you know a thong that
was tan skin colored which I thought
they were gonna leave on but clearly
they didn't okay if you had a follower
they airbrushed it out isn't that
amazing it they can't even see that
ruins everything for me look but even
the horse is disgusted in the photo
you're gonna airbrush out a song I
didn't realize they could do that I will
pose nude if I can wear a lot of clothes
and have them airbrushed out and then my
body replaced with a much better body
that's the deal I want